okay so she dumped you
why did she dump you what did you tell
yourself okay what did she tell you
she she tells me uh i don't pay
enough attention to her i don't talk to
her she stayed
in miami at my apartment ridge for three
months
she didn't do my laundry okay and i had
four days straight i'm waiting for this
girl to do my laundry
i'm thinking what the hell should i do
should i take her to gainesville
back home where she lives did you
did you tell her to take care of the
laundry for you she don't want to
clean my laundry she don't want to clean
my room she don't want to cook i don't
want to do nothing
did you did you ask her did you ask her
to take care of the laundry for you
huh did you did you ask her to take care
of the laundry for you or did you just
like you know
expect her to do it by osmosis from the
very beginning
i talked about what i need out of a
woman okay so what did she say to you
she said she's gonna give me what i need
but then she's alive she's just
flip-flop
okay so why didn't you get rid of her
then i got rid of her
she keep coming back she wouldn't let me
get rid of her she showed me at my house
she knows where i'm gonna go she goes
there and over here i'm just
i'm over here trying to make it you know
i'm trying to like i took very well when
i was with her last year
okay okay let me ask you this question
let me just ask you this question so
that we can try to stay on topic and and
get this moving in the right direction
i've got a magic wand that i can produce
for my desk i can waver right now to
solve your problem what does that look
like for you
make it stop sucking make what stops
sucking
uh the feeling because now she got
i found out i will tell you what the
problem is
okay i will i will tell you what this
what the problem is you found out today
that she's seeing uh somebody else right
no her parents marrying her off
i asked her is this what you want her
parents are marrying her off
yes to her cousin her parents are
marrying her off to her cousin
and she's a chick that would not do your
laundry cook or clean
while she stayed at your house for free
while you're in law school
so why do you care hold on hold on
listen to me
why do you care why don't you have other
options
it's not that i don't have other options
no you don't have other options because
if you had other options then you'd let
her go and you would just next her
but you don't have other options don't
you you know what my other options is
rich
my own other options is focusing on my
[ __ ] self and doing what i need to do
to be successful and achieve my goals
which i am doing i'm doing what do you
mean you're talking about women only
men love to complicate men men love to
complicate their lives and justify why
they do it that's exactly what you're
doing right now
you're you're hung up on this one girl
that you've got one itis for that's
getting married off to somebody else
that who's
realistically utterly useless no hi no
high value man would let a chick live in
his house for free
and she's not doing anything around the
house
but the problem is that you can't
enforce that boundary because
you're not a high value guy
i mean take a look in the mirror like i
can see two chins from where i'm looking
yo you're telling me i know i'm fat okay
i know i'm i'm
right so if you want so if you want to
have other options you got to get your
health in order dude like you're 23 you
should not look like that at 23.
yeah i agree it's not a good angle but
that's no fun so there's
so there's that so there's that then you
got to look at your style bro like
you can get way better looking glasses
than the ones you got on right now you
got to get your haircut you know cleaned
up i don't know if you
i like this this is my favorite [ __ ]
glasses and this is seven dollar
zeni optical this is listen something
you need to know about me
um my name is uncle sis i feel like i'm
180 years old
you know ben mala why do you why do you
call yourself uncle sees
that wasn't called me i i work in a law
office
i was 18 right fresh out of high school
and everybody at this office i give
advice to everybody they have [ __ ]
relationship problems
okay so they call you uncle then right
just because you're like the
uncle that they want to go to for so
they called me
okay got it got it okay but you don't go
walking around a woman
you know telling them to call you uncle
sees right i don't
but i made this who are you hey i'm seas
i'm in law school i'm 23 i'm going to be
a lawyer soon i'll be a partner in a law
firm that's what i'm up to who are you
again
yeah okay you need to have you need to
have
like an air of confidence around
yourself
and the ability to take some criticism
because right now you're sucking at it
dude
because all you're doing is okay but
what you're doing
what you're doing though is you're not
listening to what i'm talking about
and then you're and then you're
basically spitting up the prescription
that i've given you
right i need you to hear me out here bro
like if you want to get some better
results
you got to pay attention here first of
all you got to start by reading some of
the books that i've outlined my book
rollo's book series some evo psych so
you understand what drives desire in
women
you just can't have a chick over your
house and say do my laundry and make me
a sandwich
if you look the way that you do she can
do better than you do that's why she
left that's why she's letting her
parents marry her off
to some other schmuck she came back to
me but i didn't want it again
oh yeah okay that's why she's getting
married off right i mean
let's take a look at what she's doing
right now
right don't argue with me dude you've
got weight to lose you have a style you
have to have a look
that women are going to be attracted to
so that you can lay the boundaries
and drop the hammer and say do me a
favor can you take care of that laundry
for me and she
and she hops and skips to it and irons
the [ __ ] for you too and takes whatever
needs to get dry cleaned
over the dry cleaners because she's in
your frame
and she's listening to what you say
because she respects and values you
point blank period you're telling me
lose some [ __ ] weight
make myself better that's that's a
starting point that is a starting point
guys guys come to the red pill okay you
know what i'm going to show you a tweet
because this is because this is all
going to tie it together for you
and then we'll be able to wrap up rule
zero dad i know sometimes he doesn't you
know he's in the chat i haven't seen him
here in a little bit let me grab his
tweet because this was like
off the [ __ ] top shelf man this will
this will exemplify
exactly what we're looking at here where
did he go
i'm just gonna have to try to
regurgitate if i can't find it my
timeline here come on where are you
no don't see it must have got pushed
down but he said something along the
lines of guys come to the red pill and
then they're given
advice like get in shape so that you
actually look good naked okay like
you're not a fat
[ __ ] get in shape i'm serious dude
like two-thirds of the north american
population is out of shape
get your life in order you're 23 years
old you don't even look 23
okay start there don't
don't and don't [ __ ] argue with me
start there one
two here's some resources that you
should pay attention to
how long have you watched my channel at
least six months
six months how many times have i
mentioned read my book how many times
have i mentioned read rollo's books
have you read those books let me tell
you and you haven't read them
stop talking stop talking because you're
pissing me off i want you to listen
to me okay so you're told to lose weight
you're told to get in shape you're told
to pay attention these resources
and then go and act on them you won't
even start by listening to the advice
that i'm giving to you
you're out of here bro i'm done
you